I seek refuge in Allah from Satan the
accursed.
In the name of Allah most gracious, most
merciful.
Oh you who believe, fear Allah as he
should be feared,
and die not except in a state of Islam.
And hold fast all together by the rope
which Allah stretches out for you.
And be not divided among yourselves.
And remember with gratitude Allah's
favor on you for you were enemies and he
joined your hearts in love so that by
his grace you became brethren and you
were on the brink of the pit of fire and
he saved you from it. Thus does Allah
make his signs clear to you that you may
be guided.
Let there arise out of few a band of
people inviting to all that is good,
enjoining what is right and forbidding
what is wrong. They are the ones to
attain felicity. Rarely Allah has spoken
the truth.
Asalam allaykumah.
I request brother Tanir Shikh to kindly
distribute the schedule for the day and
all the 45 days of the course. Please,
has everyone received their copies of
the schedule?
Alhamdulillah. During the entire course
of the program, inshallah, every day
you'll be receiving a sheet which has
the daily schedule in it. What sessions
we are going to have and what topics are
we going to discuss. And as you could
see in the first day,
the introduction and objectives of the
international dhawa training program,
this heading is the theme of the day.
And every day, inshallah, we're going to
have a unique theme for the day.
So let me quickly run through the
schedule for the day. International Dawa
training program conceived, developed
and conducted by Dr. Zakir Nay the first
day Saturday 16th of January 2016 at
Mumbai India
the theme for the day is introduction
and objectives of the international
dhava training program
the first session we started off at 8:00
sharp alhamdulillah
for one hour the registration and
orientation of the participants
From 9:00 a.m. to 9:20 a.m. we saw the
entry of the participants and seating of
the participants of the international
da'wah training program.
From 9:20 a.m. to 9:30 a.m.
for 10 minutes we heard the of the
Quran. I hope you all enjoyed it.
Followed by its English translation.
Now 9:30 to 9:35 we are reading out the
schedule for the day.
Followed by this I will read inshallah
the schedule and timetable of the 33day
international dhawa training program
after which Dr. Zakir Nay inshallah will
come on the stage to start off with
rules and regulations of the
international dhawa training program and
that would be for 40 minutes.
After that, we will have a tea break
from 10:30 a.m. to 11:00 a.m. for 30
minutes.
Then from 11:00 to 12:30 p.m., we have
the self introduction of the
participants for 4 minutes each. I hope
everyone's prepared with their
introduction to come on the stage and
introduce themselves for 4 minutes.
After which from 12:30 p.m. to 1:00 p.m.
we have the objectives of the
international dhawa training program
discussed by none other than Dr. Zakir
Nay and that would be for 30 minutes
again 1:00 p.m. to 1:15 p.m. we break
for our Zohar salah. From 1:15 p.m. to
2:15 p.m. we take a lunch. From 2:15
p.m. to 2:45 p.m. That is the third
session. The earlier one was the second
session starting with the self
introduction of the participants. The
third session would begin wherein Dr.
Zakyunak will continue the objectives of
the international dhawa training program
for 30 minutes followed by the
introduction of international dhawa
training program again for 1 hour by Dr.
Zakir Nay. Then you get an opportunity
to question him. We have a question and
answer session from 3:45 p.m. to 4:15
p.m. for 30 minutes. Dr. Zak and I
inshallah would entertain your
questions. 4:15 p.m. we break for the
assur salah and that would be for 15
minutes followed by the tea break from
4:30 p.m. to 5:00 p.m. for 30 minutes.
And last the fourth session and the last
session of the day from 5:00 p.m. to
6:30 p.m. we have analyzing the seven
expectations of the participants of the
international dawa training program.
Alhamdulillah the participants have
submitted their expectations and we are
going to have an interactive session
with Dr. Zakir Nayak dealing with this
and finally we conclude with the mak
salah at 6:30 p.m. inshallah. I request
all the brothers to turn to the other
sheet which gives you the schedule of
the 45 days of the dha training program.
International Dawa training program
conceived developed and conducted by Dr.
Zakir Naik 16th January to 29th February
2016 Mumbai India. This is the schedule
of the 45day Dava training program
inshallah.
Serial number one the day one 16th of
January 2016 Saturday
introduction and objectives of the
international dhawa training program. As
I said earlier all these are the themes
for the different days. So inshallah we
will quickly run through them. Serial
number two day two 17th of January 2016
on Sunday that is tomorrow introduction
to dawa this is the theme and the third
some relief to the participants
on the 18th of January on Monday it's a
rest day rest including the homework
inshallah
day four serial number four 19th of
January 2016 Tuesday we have techniques
of giving Islamic talks. Serial number
five day four of the tawa training
program 20th of January 2016 Wednesday
we have implementation of techniques of
giving Islamic talks.
Serial number six day five 21st of
January 2016 Thursday we have the theme
structure and content of Islamic talks.
Serial number seven 22nd of January 2016
a Friday inshallah would be a rest day
along with the Friday prayers and the
homeworks. Serial number eight, day six,
23rd of January, 2016, Saturday. We have
the theme, Ancillary Aids for Islamic
Public Talks.
Serial number nine, day seven, 24th of
January, 2016. On Sunday, we have the
theme dawa through satellite TV
channels. Serial number 10, 25th of
January, 2016, which is a Monday. Again,
a rest day along with the homework.
Serial number 11, day 8 of the Dawa
training program. 26th of January, 2016,
Tuesday, we have fundamentals of Islam.
Serial number 12, day 9, 27th of
January, 2016, we have on Wednesday,
replies to most common questions asked
by non-Muslims about Islam, which is the
day one. It's going to be there for 3
days, inshallah. Serial number 13, day
10 on the 28th of January, 2016. On
Thursday, we have replies to most common
questions asked by non-Muslims about
Islam. Day two, serial number 14, 29th
of January, 2016, Friday. Again, we have
the Friday Juma prayers, rest day, as
well as the homework. Serial number 15,
day 11, 30th of January, 2016, Saturday,
we have replies to most common questions
asked by non-Muslims about Islam. Day
three serial number 16 day 12 31st of
January 2016 Sunday we have replies to
most common questions asked by
non-Muslims who have some knowledge of
Islam different set of questions other
than the most common questions and this
is the day one serial number 17 the 1st
of February 2016 Monday again a rest day
and homework this inshallah would be
maintained throughout the dawa training
program except for the last Monday.
Inshallah Mondays and Fridays would be
the rest days and homework
Allah
All
I